[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 1er juin voici le programme de
ce soir
Adoma le premier opérateur de logement
social et l'étincelle le dispositif
départemental dédié à l'accueil des
femmes victimes de violence ont décidé
de collaborer pour renforcer leur
travail auprès des femmes en danger par
quels moyens on en parle avec les deux
structures mieux manger certes mais
surtout mieux manger localement quatre
mois après les premières assises de
l'alimentation le département dévoile 6
axes en faveur du bien manger yvelinois
ont fait le point avec la
vice-présidente déléguée à l'agriculture
et aujourd'hui marque également le début
du Mois Molière chaque mois de juin la
ville de Versailles s'éveille avec le
rire le drame la musique et la danse
pour mettre à l'honneur l'un des plus
emblématiques dramaturge de France plus
de 300 représentations sont prévues avec
de nombreux spectacles gratuits nous
retrouverons notre la liste Régine
ralech sur place et en plateau avec moi
des invités Pauline vincourt Lefebvre
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
vice-présidente déléguée à
l'alimentation pour le département des
Yvelines début février le département
lancé ses premières assises de
l'alimentation 4 mois après qu'elle est
le bilan quel est le premier bilan alors
le premier bilan est plutôt positif
parce qu'à l'issue de cette
consultation plus d'une soixantaine de
propositions ont été faites et il est
également positif parce que
ce travail les participants qui venaient
d'horizon très divers
allaient finalement avec des
problématiques des interdits différents
à aller finalement dans le même sens
celui de soutenir notre agriculture et
de travailler sur la question de la
souveraineté alimentaire alors à
l'échelle de notre territoire mais sujet
de la souveraineté alimentaire qui est
un sujet plus qu'actuelle aujourd'hui et
donc vous avez dévoilé 6 axes de travail
on en parlera un peu plus tard dans
cette émission avec nous également un
plateau Teau Moura de boutois bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
territorial des Yvelines d'adomas et
Isabelle Morette la directrice de
l'étincelle bonsoir bonsoir alors vous
avez décidé de collaborer ensemble pour
renforcer votre travail concernant les
violences faites aux femmes comment est
née cette collaboration
et bien je vais démarrer
tout à fait merci beaucoup nous sommes
rencontrés lors d'une réunion en
préfecture lors de la cage avait
présenté l'étincelle ce qui était
l'étincelle mouradoutois montrer un
intérêt pour notre travail et nous nous
sommes
rapprochés de manière à voir comment
nous équipe pouvait travailler ensemble
tout à fait en fait
Adoma logement très social nous faisons
un travail au quotidien de gestion de
proximité on développe le partenaire
pour apporter des solutions à notre
public on a en charge la nécessité
d'accompagner vers le logement pour
qu'il retourne au logement Périn dans le
locatif et parmi nos publics ils
rencontrent certains nombre de
difficultés mes équipes de la filière
sociale gestion travail au quotidien et
on a tissé ce partenariat comme on l'a
fait avec d'autres et une convention en
début d'année a été signée par notre
directeur général Monsieur Emmanuel
Ballu avec l'appui bien entendu de
l'Île-de-France par Myriam berghout
notre directrice régionale
de ce partenariat plus en détail dans
quelques instants et enfin nous sommes
aussi avec un journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 Nicolas dandry
bonsoir Mathilde alors dans quelques
instants vous allez nous présenter les
informations du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines mais tout de suite on retrouve
notre journaliste Régine ralech sur
place qui est en direct à Versailles
pour l'ouverture du Mois Molière
oui bonjour Mathilde alors je suis
justement dans la cour de la Grande
Écurie du château de Versailles et ce
soir c'est la première représentation
théâtrale de l'événement le Mois Molière
et ce soir on va commencer par
braconnier et je suis justement avec
eric Bouvron son metteur en scène
bonsoir bonsoir alors eric Bouvron
justement aujourd'hui ouvre le Mois
Molière avec votre toute dernière
création de quoi ça parle en quelques
mots braconnie
vers mon Afrique mon Afrique à moi j'ai
grandi c'est une histoire de Power
Wright et Cynthia qui tient un Safari
Lodge pour des touristes et pour mettre
un combat contre le braconnage et un
soir ce rhinocéros Umba qu'elle a il
avait comme son propre fils se fait tuer
par deux braconniers
pour lui ça devient personnel il est
pourchasse il réussit de tuer l'un de
ses braconniers trois jours plus tard
James
à 300 km viens récupérer le corps pour
l'enterrer mais il y a une quatrième
personnage le fils aîné le frère du
cadavre et lui il veut de la vengeance
et justement dans cette pièce on parle
de l'amour des animaux mais aussi de
vengeance on venait de le dire pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez choisi d'aborder
ces thèmes est-ce que ce sont des choses
qui vous touchent particulièrement
l'Afrique du Sud ou dans où j'ai grandi
n'est plus le même d'aujourd'hui mais il
y a encore des questionnements sur les
générations donc c'est plutôt ce que
cette histoire aborde c'est juste une
histoire mais qui a pris des proportions
que j'attendais pas parce que je me suis
inspiré des gens qui existent réellement
dans des situations concrètes donc et
des thèmes qui apparaissent entre le
choc des cultures les traditions le choc
entre ce qui croit beaucoup à préserver
les animaux et pour eux pour d'autres ou
les animaux ne sont pas prioritaires
donc toutes ces questions écologiques
relations homme en animal
ressort à travers cette histoire très
très simple mais assez puissant et
universel quelque part
comme dans beaucoup de vos pièces vous
nous faites voyager donc là on part
justement en Afrique du Sud ce qui est
étonnant aussi c'est que dans cette
pièce l'espace est très épuré il y a
très peu de décors pourquoi comment
est-ce que vous expliquez ce choix je
crois que elle n'est rien plus fort que
l'imaginaire du spectateur quand on lit
un livre qui fait le travail c'est c'est
toi la lectrice c'est juste de l'encre
sur du papier et pareil la scène nous
oblige vu le cadre est tellement limité
de réinventer et mon travail c'est de
créer cette miroir où j'invite le
spectateur de le traverser pour que son
imaginaire ouvre et lui il crée avec les
artistes donc c'est c'est des années de
travail qui m'a amené à comprendre ça et
c'est comment on fait en Afrique
également c'est mon ma formation en tant
que artiste Afrique d'origine est-ce
qu'il y a un peu de fierté aujourd'hui
pour vous de pouvoir représenter cette
pièce au Mois Molière qui est aussi un
événement incontournable d'ici à
Versailles je pense que c'est sautant
privilège pour moi monsieur demaziere et
madame Lefebvre qui qui mène ce festival
depuis toutes ces années
on a fait connaissance en 2015 je pense
et depuis
qui ont resté fidèles mais à mes œuvres
qui encouragent c'est important pour un
créateur auteur d'avoir des gens qui qui
te qui te font confiance et là cette
fois-ci c'est le premier pièce que
Monsieur demoiselle n'a pas vu on va
oser ouvrir le festival en plus en me
donnant carte blanche comme ça ça montre
un peu l'amitié la fidélité donc comme
je dis c'est un privilège dans un pays
qui puisse mener les festivals comme ça
c'est
précieux bien merci beaucoup
Eric bouffon et je le rappelle le moins
Molière aura lieu donc tout le mois de
juin et ce jusqu'au 2 juillet les places
partent très vite alors si vous voulez
réserver une deuxième session de
réservation de place sera ouverte le 6
juin
et merci beaucoup à vous Régine Rallet
pour toutes ces précisions et à Céline
Charles au moyen technique dans cette
émission également nous aurons des
balades en Valais de Chevreuse du sport
mais également nos idées de sortie dans
les Yvelines mais avant je vous propose
de jeter un coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera bleu et
ensoleillé au niveau des températures il
fera 13 degrés à Houdan Mantes-la-Jolie
et Versailles et 12 degrés à Rambouillet
dans l'après-midi le soleil sera
toujours au beau fixe côté température
comptait 22 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles 21 à Houdan et 22 à
Rambouillet et demain nous fêterons les
blandines le point maintenant sur les
informations du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines
c'est le jour J pour les étudiants et
les étudiantes la phase d'admission
principale de parcoursup s'ouvre
aujourd'hui oui effectivement à 19h
précisément et les élèves auront
jusqu'au 7 juillet pour faire leur choix
les 917 000 candidats pourront consulter
les premières réponses des
établissements auxquels ils ont fait des
vœux les dossiers sont actualisés chaque
matin jusqu'au 6 juillet en fonction des
listes d'attentes alors un peu de
pédagogie si votre réponse est oui alors
c'est que vous êtes admis attention il
vous faut cependant répondre rapidement
il y a des délais bien précis qui sont
affichés dans le dossier en face de la
proposition d'admission deuxième partie
si vous êtes en liste d'attentes il vous
faudra attendre qu'une place se libère
enfin c'est la réponse est NON à l'issue
de la phase d'admission une phase
complémentaire ouvrira le 15 juin dans
laquelle il vous sera possible de
formuler jusqu'à 10 nouveaux vœux dans
des formations disposant encore de place
on poursuit avec l'image du jour Nicolas
pour célébrer la dernière étape du Tour
de France au du Vélodrome national de 50
ans en Yvelines ce sera le 23 juillet le
département des Yvelines et la ville de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux organise la fête
du tour
de vélo terre de cyclisme le vélodrome
accueille aujourd'hui et demain 600
collégiens désibles durant ces deux
jours les élèves assistent à plusieurs
animations et activités et on écoute un
des organisateurs au micro de Julien
Leroy les collégiens qui sont présents
donc aujourd'hui jeudi et demain
vendredi
ils ont en fait trois axes de présence
sur site donc ils vont découvrir un
petit peu la pédagogie routière avec la
mission sécurité routière le 10 et nous
comité départemental qui sommes
responsables de la voirie mais ils ont
aussi voilà une découverte du vélo avec
cette recycloie sportive qui leur fait
tout simplement découvrir comment
fonctionne un vélo le savoir où la vélo
qui leur permet aussi d'avoir les bonnes
pratiques et la bonne sensibilisation
sur route et ils ont aussi tout un volet
pratique ludique avec du BMX du VTT du
kart à dans lequel en fait ils
ont juste à s'éclater
et la fête du Tour se poursuit le samedi
3 et le dimanche 4 juin au Vélodrome et
cette fois-ci c'est pour le grand public
avec plusieurs animations il y aura du
BMX du cyclisme artistique ou encore du
kart à des baptêmes sur piste et
de BMX seront aussi offerts sur
inscription au programme également des
ateliers réparation de vélo une color
run ou encore un concert de l'orchestre
de l'Alliance accompagnée de
chaux-de-france cycliste les opposants à
la ligne 18 vont partir du camp dans
lequel il s'était établi depuis plus de
deux ans sur le plateau de sa clé
Nicolas oui effectivement Mathilde les
occupants de la zate de Saclay ont
décidé de partir de même en cause les
fortes pression mise sur les
propriétaires des terres agricoles qui
leur avait été prêté pour établir la ZAD
ces derniers s'exposaient à de fortes
amendes si le camp n'était pas levé
rapidement parce qu'il y a une procédure
judiciaire qui est en cours et bien ce
sera chose faite ce dimanche 4 juin
d'ici là les occupants organisent des
braderies pour donner des palettes de la
vaisselle ou encore de la literie pour
rappel les occupants font partie du
collectif contre la ligne 18 une ligne
du métro de 35 km dont 14 en aérien qui
devraient relier à l'horizon 2030
l'aéroport d'Orly à Versailles d'igares
seront desservis donc Guyancourt même si
le collectif des ménages il entend bien
continuer la lutte et le jeu c'était job
revient à Trappes Nicolas quel est
l'objectif et bien Mathilde l'objectif
c'est de faire rencontrer des demandeurs
d'emploi et des employeurs à travers le
sport ça souvent ce sont des jeunes
issus de quartiers prioritaires donc là
ça se fera sur un cours de tennis une
manière de briser la glace et de faire
tomber les clichés après une première
édition en 2022 demandeur d'emploi et
recruteur et vont revenir sur les cours
de tennis on est en pleine période de
Roland-Garros ce sera au complexe
Jacques monco de Trappes jeudi 8 juin
l'après-midi se déroulera en deux
parties d'abord initiation au tennis qui
seront proposés avec ensuite des
coachings de soft skills ce qu'on
appelle et bien c'est précieux conseils
qu'on peut avoir et qui peuvent être
donnés à des demandeurs d'emploi pour
réussir leur entretien d'embauche et
puis ensuite il y aura une phase
d'entretien qui seront proposées aux
d'un modèle de recrutement qui
fonctionne l'association socio-sportive
faite le mur qui organise l'événements
affiches plus de 20% de sortie positive
des jobs dating si vous êtes intéressé
vous pouvez vous inscrire auprès de
l'IFP de trappes et à partir de demain
Météo France lance la météo des forêts
alors la météo des forêts les fortes
chaleurs qui arrivent vous le savez on
est au début de l'été bah il y a des
risques d'incendie et qui qui sont qui
sont forts et bien on a vu par exemple
ce dimanche ou un premier feu de forêt
s'est déclaré à son champ dans les
Yvelines et bien pour prévenir ses feux
Météo France va publier tous les jours
et pendant toute la période estivale sur
son site et sur l'application sa
première météo des forêts l'objectif
c'est d'informer les Français sur le
niveau de danger de feu en métropole et
faire appel à leur bon sens en cas de
risque élevé quatre niveaux de danger de
feu seront présentés vers jaune orange
et rouge et vous voulez terminer par une
dernière information Nicolas une
dernière information de dernière minute
qui nous ont parvenus par mail tu viens
à communiquer à la préfecture des
Yvelines annonce la création d'un fond
départemental de revitalisation des
Yvelines l'objectif c'est d'accompagner
les projets de création d'emploi dans le
département elles sont éligibles et TPE
PME et uti qui sont implantés ou encore
d'implantation dans le département et
donc c'est un fond de rivet de
revitalisation qui est doté de près de
600000 € avec des prêts qui vont être
engagés dans dans les prochaines
semaines on peut postuler et candidater
et avoir des informations sur le site de
la Chambre de commerce d'industrie et de
la préfecture merci beaucoup Nicolas
dandry pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous
voyez une image ou une information qui
vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news
on en parlait en début d'émission Adoma
le premier opérateur de logement social
et l’étincelle le dispositif
départemental dédié à l'accueil des
femmes victimes de violence ont signé un
partenariat pour aider les femmes en
danger pour parler avec nous Isabelle
Morette la directrice de l'étincelle et
Mourad boutewa le directeur territorial
des Yvelines dadoma alors on a parlé un
peu de comment est-ce qui était né cette
collaboration ce partenariat pourquoi
est-ce que vous avez décidé bah de
collaborer ensemble alors moi tout
d'abord ce qui m'a intéressé et séduit
dans ce partenariat nécessaire par
rapport à notre public c'est le service
public le côté anonyme est gratuit et la
proximité pour venir auprès de ce public
là la première étape c'était un numéro
de téléphone la structure sur Montigny
de pouvoir pour notre public et faire
une victime de violence de démarcher et
la démarche du bureau mobile et le
partenariat qui s'inscrivait dans la
continuité c'est d'aller au plus près et
peut-être aussi repérer celles qui
n'osent pas et parce que étincelle vient
à eux
mobile l'étincelle en quelques en
quelques mots
l'étincelle en effet accueil de jour
départementale pour les femmes victimes
de violence donc il ne faut pas oublier
que nous sommes un établissement public
et nous avons décidé l'an passé de
pouvoir pardonner moi aller vers les
femmes victimes de violence qui ne nous
connaissent pas qui n'osent pas passer
notre porte ou tout simplement qui se
trouve dans des endroits des Yvelines
qui sont plus éloignés d'un tissu
partenariat et donc ça passe par un
camion qui se déplace partout dans les
Yvelines oui on l'appelle un bureau
mobile parce que pour nous c'est un
c'est un autre bureau c'est un bureau
qui est sur vous souhaite qui est mobile
mais nous essayons d'avoir tout le
confort que nous pouvons avoir également
à l'accueil de jour qui se trouve à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux alors qu'est-ce
que va apporter ce bureau mobile
l'étincelle les trous plus près des
femmes oui c'est quelque chose qui
n'existe pas lorsque vous êtes en zone
rurale ou lorsque vous pouvez
difficilement sortir de chez vous et
bien nous nous allons verser femme qui
ont besoin de d'accompagnement et qui
vont peu à peu par notre communication
par notre présence chez Adoma qui et par
d'autres présences d'autres permanences
autorisées par le fait que certains
maires s'intéressent également à notre à
notre projet et bien ces femmes vont
pouvoir être écoutées accompagnés et
orienté selon leurs besoins alors on
voit à l'écran s'afficher les prochaines
permanences enfin les prochaines villes
dans lequel sera ce bureau mobile c'est
vile vous les avez comment est-ce que
vous les avez choisi c'était en
collaboration avec Adoma justement en
partie oui et pour le reste et je
laisserai après la parole à amour à
boutois en partie puisque nous avons
écrit à tous les maires des Yvelines en
leur proposant nos services
nous avons eu une vingtaine de réponses
immédiatement après notre notre annonce
notre premier annonce puis par la suite
et bien certains partenaires sont venus
vers nous et le fait qu'adoma vienne à
nous nous ouvrait également la
possibilité d'aller dans les directement
en compte
on est venu dans la structure avec
l'ensemble de mes responsables de
résidence puisqu'on a 26 résidences sur
16 communes le parc ce partenariat
nécessitait d'être conforté et
le fait qu'il vienne sur les structures
au plus près proposé ce service là j'ai
toujours une pensée à celle qui n'ose
pas nous en parler à nous il y a un a on
sait qu'elles ont été victimes qu'elles
ont eu à passer ou qu'ils ont pu vivre
des choses difficiles par rapport à ce
sujet là mais ce qui était important
c'est de permettre et d'avoir ce service
public au plus près comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure dans le cadre du travail
partenariat et dans le cas du travail de
proximité que nous faisons au quotidien
sur nos structures
juste un mot sur votre engagement voit
demain parce que c'est pas votre premier
coeur de métier disons de lutter contre
les violences faites aux femmes ça c'est
votre spécialité par contre du côté de
l'étincelle en quoi pour un bailleur
social comme Adoma c'est important de
s'engager
dans ce combat-là et comment de quelle
manière mis à part cette ce partenariat
que vous avez avec l'étincelle alors ce
partenariat s'inscrit parmi tant
d'autres avec des conventions aussi que
l'on signe sur l'ensemble des sujets sur
ce sujet là c'est une cause qui est
portée non seulement sur les Yvelines
mais elle est portée comme je l'ai dit
c'est la raison pour laquelle de
directeur général en personne Monsieur
Emmanuel Ballu directeur général d'Adoma
est venu signer à convention dans le
quotidien nous avons des permanences
avec des partenaires autres aussi qui
sont à l'écoute et lorsqu'on repère des
personnes qui ont une problématique
notre rôle à nous c'est de les
accompagner et de les orienter vers et
donc c'est dans ce cadre là que parmi le
public nous accueillons et les
difficultés qu'on peut rencontrer qu'on
va solutionner sur tous les autres
thématiques sur celui là
partenariat le partenariat était un ciel
répond favorablement à nos attentes
c'est par exemple un voisin qui peut
entendre ce qui se passe dans une
résidence c'est qui vient s'il vous
signaler des violences alors merci pour
ça parce qu'en fait ce que je souhaite
c'est que ce scénario là existe une
personne va rentrer chez nous qui
n'évoque pas qu'elle a été victime de
violence on lui a loué un logement au
rez-de-chaussée et en fait il y a une
appréhension d'occuper un logement
rez-de-chaussée donc et elle va dévoiler
que la problématique qu'elle a eu c'est
victime de violence ce qui m'a intéressé
donc le bureau mobile c'est d'éveiller
une curiosité parce qu'il vient dans nos
structures d'une manière anonyme encore
une fois et donc mon rôle à moi n'est
pas d'aller à la recherche de celle qui
aurait pu l'être qui pourrait l'être
c'est de éveiller une curiosité de la
part de tout le monde de chacun de nous
qui soit chez nous ou pas de monter dans
le bureau parce qu'il faut monter les
deux marches pour découvrir qu'en fait
que le bureau mobile est sur cette
thématique
et ensuite que l'on soit victime qu'on
l'a été ou pas ça peut aussi intéresser
ceux qui en ont autour de autour d'eux
et dans le milieu professionnel mais
responsables connaissent bien entendu
l'ensemble de leur public les
problématiques et notre rôle encore une
fois c'est de les accompagner pour aller
vers le logement pérenne et ça passe par
ce partenariat et je remercie Isabelle
parce que c'est un sujet qui est très
largement d'actualité et qui n'est pas à
la portée de notre département mais d'où
encore une fois une cause vraiment
nationale ce sujet là et il y a aussi du
public victime de violence dans nos
structures malheureusement alors quels
seront les professionnels qui seront
présents au sein de ce bureau mobile
l'étincelle on a les mêmes
professionnels que vous pouvez retrouver
à Montigny à l'accueil de jour
c'est-à-dire 3 travailleurs sociaux qui
sont spécifiquement formés aux violences
faites aux femmes on verrait également
une psychologue ou en effet nous avons
également à bord de ce bureau mobile qui
fait 3 mètres 80
alors une nous avons été peut-être un
petit peu
nous avons souhaité surtout développer
au maximum donc dans cette structure de
3 mètres 80 pardonnez-moi 2 parties une
partie pour les travailleurs sociaux qui
vont recevoir la femme victime de
violence qui monte à bord et nous avons
également à One to One qui va permettre
à nos partenaires de monter à bord ça
peut être un moment la gendarmerie ça
peut être un avocat ça peut être un
médecin et ça peut être surtout une psy
ou nous avons deux psychologues au sein
de l'étincelle qui travaille avec nous
et qui monte à bord de ce bureau mobile
également et donc toutes les femmes
peuvent venir avec ou sans rendez-vous
oui alors les femmes majeures bien
entendu si une jeune femme mineure
venait vers nous nous la recevions sans
problème mais elle sera orientée vers
l'un de nos partenaires qui s'occupent
des jeunes femmes mineures et bien merci
beaucoup Mourad pour toi et Isabelle
Moret d'avoir accepté notre invitation
justement
nous sommes allés découvrir ce nouveau
dispositif le bureau mobile l'étincelle
c'était lors du Mobile village dans les
Yvelines plusieurs camions sillonnent
régulièrement le département pour
apporter le sport la culture ou encore
des offres de santé dans les villes
rurales l'occasion pour nous de vous
faire découvrir quelques-uns
[Musique]
je travaille pour le jobstruck qui est
un dispositif partageant entre trois
associations d'insertion professionnelle
sur les Yvelines et je suis donc
coordinatrice et pilote de ce projet
c'est l'espace d'entretien dans lequel
je peux recevoir les personnes l'idée
c'est une fois que j'ai rencontré qui
soit revenu à moi c'est de faire un
petit diagnostic pour savoir quelle est
la problématiques quelles sont les
problématiques rencontrées par les
personnes et si une structure de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
peut être une solution à ce moment-là on
va creuser un petit peu plus pour savoir
les envies et les difficultés précises
rencontrées par la personne et mon rôle
c'est ensuite de la mettre en relation
avec le bon interlocuteur nos
associations elles travaillent avec des
clients que sont des collectivités des
particuliers ou des entreprises qui nous
permettent de mettre en situation de
travail rémunéré les personnes qu'on
accompagne
je suis la directrice de l'étincelle qui
est l'accueille de jour départemental
pour les femmes victimes de violence
nous avons été donc lauréat de de France
relance ce qui nous a permis d'acquérir
ce bureau mobile pour aller vers les
femmes victimes de violence qui ne nous
connaissent pas ou qui hésiteraient à
venir jusqu'à nous qui est important
pour nous c'est de communiquer pour dire
voilà nous sommes dans ce secteur et
n'hésitez pas à venir nous voir si la
personne si la dame pousse la porte
qu'est ce qui va se passer elle va
rencontrer un travailleur social qui est
spécifiquement formé aux violences
faites aux femmes la personne va la
recevoir va l'écouter et va l'orienter
selon ses besoins
le nomadapart il y a un camion
pédagogique qui a été aménagé en
appartement témoins de manière à
présenter tout ce qui va concerner les
économies d'eau et d'énergie dans le
logement donc ça a été organisé en
présentant sur sur ma gauche tout ce qui
va être consommation d'eau et ensuite on
continue dans le logement en étudiant
tout ce qui va concerner plutôt les
équipements donc machine à laver la
vaisselle le frigidaire on parle
également qualité de l'air dans le
logement avec la ventilation et une
maquette qu'on sort à côté d'une nomade
appart
en fait le mobilforce c'est quoi c'est
un gymnase itinérant qui se balade dans
les communes et les zones rurales
notamment et en fait le but c'est
d'apporter le sport dans ces zones là et
de le proposer à n'importe qui
aujourd'hui on intervient avec des
enfants jusqu'à des personnes en
situation de handicap en passant par les
adultes les seniors les ados voilà on
peut proposer plus de 70 sports
aujourd'hui dans ce camion et la
particularité de mobile sport c'est
qu'on est plutôt sur des sports
innovants donc en fait c'est des sports
qu'ils ont pas l'habitude de voir à la
télé de pratiquer à l'école ou en dehors
dans des sections sportives donc à bord
de ce camion on retrouve des chasubles
pour faire des équipes on retrouve de
quoi délimiter les zones avec des plots
des cerceaux on a des buts aussi on a
pas mal de matos ici pour avec des
filets
alors Pauline vinocour Lefebvre quelles
sont les autres camions les autres trucs
qui sillonnent le département des
Yvelines bon alors non les appels bus
elles sont francophones
on avait commencé après les assises de
la ruralité on avait lancé un bus PMI
pour aller c'est ce que disait la
responsable de l'étincelle tout à
l'heure elle est au plus près des
habitants dans des zones rurales ou le
maintien d'une PMI en dur était pas
forcément le la solution la plus
pertinente parce que peut accessible
parce que très peu pas suffisamment
mobilisés donc on avait lancé le bus PMI
et ce système de mobilité à l'instar de
ce que c'est des artisans commerçants
autrefois dans nos villages c'est
développé on a un bus santé un bus job
insertion
on avait à l'écran en tout premier
d'ailleurs on est parteux alors je sais
pas si c'est celui du département qu'on
avait vu à l'écran Lenôtre est très rose
à l'image du département
on a
[Musique]
un partenariat aussi avec une structure
pour un bus santé femme qui est aussi
s'attaque à la problématique des
violences conjugales donc c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne et qui permet
d'aller dans les zones et dans les
quartiers politiques de la ville qui
sont dans lesquels les il y a parfois
souvent même moins de mobilité pour les
habitants donc c'est une bonne chose ça
fonctionne plutôt bien et nous avons été
rejoints par une autre journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 Gabriel Gontier
bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde avec vous on
verra comme d'habitude le jeudi les
idées de sortie dans les Yvelines en
quelques mots faites nous rêver
qu'est-ce que vous avez notamment de la
fête des mères dimanche je vous donnerai
quelques idées pour les retardataires
qui n'ont pas fait encore leurs cadeaux
peut-être ah oui c'est bien vu je suis
concernée
c'est une bonne idée ce sera enfin
démission en tout cas restez bien avec
nous on va parler des assises de
l'alimentation début février le
département des Yvelines lancé ses
premières assises de l'alimentation
l'objectif favoriser la production
locale et faire progresser les circuits
courts alors 4 mois après quel est le
bilan pour en parler avec nous Pauline
vinocourt Lefebvre pour commencer
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui vous a
poussé à créer ses premières assises de
l'alimentation pourquoi il y en a pas eu
avant et c'est cette année que vous avez
décidé de les lancer
alors ça pourquoi il y en a pas eu avant
Joker en tout cas la raison sérieusement
la raison pour laquelle on les a lancé
enfin il y a plusieurs raisons d'abord
on a mis en place il y a quelques années
un système original pour alimenter les
cantines de nos collèges une structure
qui s'appelle ce midi et qui a la
différence d'une simple délégation de
service public on a un prestataire mais
on siège avec lui dans le conseil
d'administration de la sémop société
d'économie mixte à objet unique
et l'un des objectifs de ces midi
c'était d'avoir plus de produits locaux
dans les assiettes de des collégiens
pour travailler avec nos producteurs et
pas ce qu'on considère que ça a aussi du
sens de consommer local et que ça peut
pérenniser restructurer des filières et
soutenir nos agriculteurs qui en ont
quand même bien besoin ensuite se pose
aujourd'hui avec sans doute plus
d'acuité qui a quelques années la
question de la souveraineté aliment
faire sur laquelle on a décidé de
travailler à l'échelle de notre
territoire donc plus de local dans les
assiettes de collégiens au départ mais
soutenir nos agriculteurs ensuite et
avant tout et travailler sur cette
question de la souveraineté alimentaire
alors bien sûr à l'échelle d'un
territoire on peut pas forcément
répondre à tous les besoins avec les
producteurs yvelin peut-être parce qu'il
y a certains produits qu'on n'a pas
suffisamment dans les Yvelines on
s'interdit pas évidemment de travailler
à l'échelle régionale ou en proximité
avec des départements limitrophes quand
c'est nécessaire évidemment alors on le
sait les coups de production sont
nettement moins élevés pour les grands
groupes industriels c'est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles les Français
décident de moins manger local ou de
moins privilégier les circuits courts
comment est-ce que vous comptez
accroître justement ces circuits courts
et les petits producteurs sans augmenter
les tarifs et notamment pour les
cantines
alors dans les cantines du département
le prix de l'assiette augmente
sensiblement quand même à partir du
moment où on fait rentrer plus de
produits locaux
voilà parce que il y a les coûts de
production mais pas que quand on parle
de circuit court on parle à la fois de
proximité et de
d'intermédiaires c'est-à-dire que le
circuit court c'est aussi celui qui va
le plus rapidement possible du champ à
l'assiette or toujours l'exemple des
carottes parce qu'il est assez
emblématique et que les collégiens
mangent des carottes
la carotte les carottes qui sont
produites chez nos producteurs il est
bien évident qu'ils peuvent pas aller on
a 115 collèges dans les Yvelines ils
peuvent pas aller en livrer 3 kilos par
ci 18 kg par là etc donc on a besoin
d'un maillon logistique parce que c'est
pas notre métier parce que c'est pas
celui de du prestataire de restauration
donc ça
voilà c'est aussi c'est aussi un sujet
après pour ce qui est du consommateur il
y avait effectivement un groupe de
travail il y avait huit groupes de
travail dans ces assises un sur la resto
et un sur la fidélisation des
consommateurs parce qu'on a constaté
après le covid pendant le covid les gens
sont allés dans leur ferme acheter ce
qu'il fallait le temps alors Isabelle
aller au supermarché au début de la
crise covid c'était assez anxiogène
finalement
et je pense aussi que c'était l'occasion
de sortir de prendre l'air et de signer
son petit bon de sortie et d'aller se
balader dans la campagne après le covid
beaucoup de producteurs qui font de la
vente à faire ou qui ont des boutiques
en direct nous disent on est retombé à
un niveau plus bas qu'avant covid donc
il y a sûrement la question du temps de
l'accessibilité et puis la question du
prix et dans les groupes de dans le
groupe de travail sur ces sujets là il y
avait aussi la difficultés parfois à
trouver les produits à savoir de quoi on
parle nous dans les Yvelines on les a
déjà référencé on met à jour la liste
des producteurs d'autres structures
l'ont fait je sais qu'à la région ils
ont ministres régionales certaines
interco comme GPSO ont listé aussi leurs
producteurs donc il y a une réflexion
sur le ou les outils qu'on pourrait
mettre au service alors peut-être des
communes peut-être des intercos en tout
cas du plus grand nombre pour faire
connaître ses producteurs c'est vrai que
c'est aussi un sujet après la question
du coup effectivement
c'est l'équation compliquée à résoudre
il faut en passer par là il faut en
passer par là mais dans nos assises on
sait aussi penché sur le sujet de la
précarité alimentaire pour voir comment
dans les circuits de distribution
alimentaire pour les plus fragiles on
pouvait avoir plus de produits locaux
aussi justement vous commencez à
travailler sur ces questions des coûts
vous avez des petites billes pour pour
peut-être les réduire petit à petit et
puis qu'on enlève un petit peu cette
image de mon dessin
local c'est accessible que au plus
riches finalement d'entre nous c'est pas
toujours plus cher cela dit c'est pas
toujours plus cher dans les cantines par
exemple les plats sont peut-être un peu
plus chers oui alors d'abord l'objectif
c'est vraiment de soutenir nos
producteurs donc ce qu'il faut c'est que
à la fin de l'exercice le producteur lui
s'y retrouve et que soit pas le prix
producteur qui soit un revenu à la
baisse c'est ça me semble important de
le rappeler quand même
ensuite vous allez mettre en place des
aides pour aider les producteurs alors
on en a déjà on va les retravailler on
votera une délibération cadre sur nos
aides agricoles on a déjà un certain
nombre d'aide ce qui est difficile c'est
qu'on est très contraint par l'Union
européenne en la matière il y a des
plafonds de minimis c'est un peu techno
mais on peut pas faire ce qu'on veut et
on peut pas faire avec les montants
qu'on veut donc c'est en plus la région
est déjà il y a déjà des partenaires oui
on est partenaires de la région sur
les l'hydrogène leaders
le département et partenaire de la
région et la crise économique et face à
au réchauffement climatique notamment
est-ce qu'il va y avoir des aides en
plus il y en a déjà et on va
retravailler notre dispositif d'aide je
peux pas vous dire ce qui lancera
exactement parce que le cadre est pas
encore défini et la fin de ses assises
finalement n'est pas une fin c'est le
démarrage de la mise en œuvre des
propositions de tout ou partie plutôt
des propositions qui ont été faites en
la matière mais pour répondre à votre
question initiale pour réduire les coûts
une petite méthode c'est par exemple
alors on parle beaucoup de d'augmenter
la part de protéines végétales dans les
assiettes et
pourquoi pas puisque s'il y a plus de
protéines végétales ça coûte un peu
moins cher que de la protéine animale ce
qui permet en contrepartie d'envisager
peut-être moins de protéines animales
mais de la protéine animale locale et
donc de soutenir la filière élevage on
n'est pas un département d'élevage mais
ça permet peut-être de renforcer et de
structurer un peu plus fortement une
filière qui a quand même
quelques producteurs sur le territoire
et quelques outils de transformation
aujourd'hui il y a des filières à
reconstruire à bâtir où il y a déjà des
filières qui sont vraiment en place dans
le département il y a des zones
maraîchères quand même on sait que le
département des Yvelines aussi est une
forte terre céréalière avec le blé le
colza mais il y a quand même des zones
qui sont maraîchères dans le département
sont en place on peut les renforcer on
a des producteurs qui sont prêts à faire
plus
sous réserve qu'en face on leur
garantissent des quantités livrables si
on augmente la part de local on les
assiettes des collégiens on va avoir
besoin d'avoir plus de sources de
producteurs parce que si une année on a
une mauvaise récolte il faut bien qu'on
ait les quantités de carottes je
reprends l'exemple de la carotte
disponible donc il y a à la fois des
filières à reconstruire je peux enfin à
renforcer je pense à l'élevage hier
j'étais à la région on parlait des
champignons voilà il y a un petit reste
de filière en Île-de-France
si on pouvait l'impréver ce serait quand
même formidable que le champignon de
Paris vienne de région parisienne voilà
il y a tous ces enjeux je crois même
qu'il en reste deux il en reste et trois
en Île-de-France juste toute dernière
question Pauline vigneaucourt quand
est-ce que c'est solution
pour être visible dans le département
quand est-ce qu'elles vont être mises en
place très rapidement il y a déjà des
choses qui sont qui sont en place ou en
expérimentation la délibération cadre
agricole ça devrait être avant la fin de
l'année pour le reste en fonction de ce
qu'on arrive à faire des contraintes
qu'on parviendra à lever de la vitesse à
laquelle on pourra le faire mais
évidemment le plus vite possible très
bien merci beaucoup
Lefebvre d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je le rappelle vous êtes la
vice-présidente déléguée à
l'alimentation pour le département des
Yvelines un peu de sport à présent dans
votre 7 8 à 100 jours de la Coupe du
monde de rugby les médailles d'or
d'argent et de bronze ont été présentés
hier au Conseil régional d'Île-de-France
leur particularité elles sont fabriquées
à partir de téléphone recyclés le
reportage de Nicolas dandry et Grégory
canalet
[Musique]
présent ce matin pour découvrir les
médailles de la Coupe du monde de rugby
2023 des présidents de clubs yvelinois
Lionel garrigue président de l'Union
centre 78 bonjour et Olivier néerneuf
secrétaire général du Rugby Club de
Versailles bonjour bonjour alors dans
quel état d'esprit vous êtes là on est à
100 jours du début de cette compétition
c'est une opportunité magnifique que
d'avoir cette Coupe du Monde
il faut remercier les instances
fédérales pour nous avoir amené jusque
là c'est c'est fabuleux on a une
opportunité fantastique celle de nous
réunir autour de la balle au vol autour
de notre passion et il y a une chose qui
est intéressante à souligner c'est qu'on
plus localement notamment on va décliner
une mini Coupe du Monde des écoles de
rugby chaque club a eu un partirage au
sort le nom d'une équipe en l'occurrence
l'URSS 78 à récupérer le l'Argentine
donc nous allons représenter l'Argentine
et tous les clubs des Yvelines ont
adhéré à cette idée de mini Coupe du
monde donc on va rencontrer les Fidji
etc enfin tenu par d'autres clubs c'est
une magnifique opportunité oui alors
Versailles sera quelle équipe du coup
dans cette mini Coupe du monde avec
surprise sans surprise on aura le Pays
de Galles nous serons sous les yeux du
pédiatre puisque le Pays de Galles
arrive fin août à Versailles et on est
ravi puisque en 2007 on avait les
Anglais déjà à Versailles ça c'était
très bien passé et là cette année avec
l'arrivée des des Gallois et ben on est
tous on est tous heureux et cette
manifestation aujourd'hui à 100 jours de
la Coupe du Monde nous fait vraiment
entrer dans le processus et alors
justement qu'est-ce qu'elle vient va
avoir bah à la fois le club peut-être de
l'UFC vous êtes vous serez juste à côté
de Versailles et le club de Versailles
avec l'équipe de du Pays de Galles
écoutez c'est tout tout reste à faire
avec l'équipe de dirigeante du Pays de
Galles quand elle va arriver quand elle
va arriver il faut absolument qu'on
puisse mettre en place des événements
des des
séances où les Gallois pourront être
présents devant les enfants les enfants
des Yvelines et les enfants des clubs de
tout près de Versailles et voilà et donc
nous sommes à 100 jours de ce premier
match France Nouvelle-Zélande le 8
septembre au Stade de France
[Musique]
et les voilà les médailles de la Coupe
du monde de rugby nous sommes à 100
jours du début de la compétition et avec
moi Jacques Rivoal le président du
comité d'organisation de la Coupe du
Monde France 2023 bonjour Jacques
bonjour
déjà un mot sur les médailles qu'est-ce
qu'a représente plein de choses en fait
ça représente tout ce qu'on veut mettre
dans la Coupe du monde donc c'est
d'abord et cette Coupe du Monde on veut
que ça sonne comme du monde de
territoire donc vous avez sur cette
médaille au verso en fait les le rubans
de Mobius qui est personnalisé à l'image
de chacun de chacune des villes hautes
qui accueillera la compétition et donc
qui illustre ce lien social ce lien
qu'on veut créer entre l'événement Coupe
du Monde et les territoires donc ça
c'est la première dimension la deuxième
dimension c'est insister sur le fait que
c'est médailles ont été fabriqués à
partir de téléphone recyclés il y a eu
200 000 téléphones recyclés qui ont
permis de fabriquer les 1491 médailles
donc ça c'est la le témoignage qu'on
veut apporter à la société démontrer que
cette coupe du monde elle aura un impact
positif en particulier sur la production
de l'environnement donc aujourd'hui
c'est un moment très important parce
qu'on dévoile ces médailles et c'est le
lancement définitif de la dernière ligne
droite de la préparation de la Coupe du
Monde de Triomphe dessus et on voit
l'Arc de Triomphe parce que l'Arc de
Triomphe c'est bien sûr la France et
l'Arc de Triomphe c'est l'endroit où
finalement on se retrouve pour célébrer
pour de faire la fête et c'est aussi
l'autre dimension qu'on veut exprimer
dans cette Coupe du monde ça sera bien
sûr une compétition sportive très très
intense avec un suspense qu'on n'a
jamais connu on ne sait vraiment pas qui
gagnera cette coupe du monde mais on
veut aussi que ça coupe du monde ça soit
une grande fête populaire voilà qui qui
va permettre aux gens de se retrouver
Parce que le rugby c'est ça c'est du
bien social c'est les gens se
rencontrent via ensemble au match qu'ils
soient supporter d'une ou de l'autre
équipe et après festivois en même temps
donc on espère qu'on va avoir une vraie
trève pendant lesquelles on a tous se
retrouver on va célébrer la fête autour
des belles valeurs du rugby grande fête
aussi qui retentira dans le département
des Yvelines de équipes viendront
s'installer pendant la compétition dans
le département les Gallois à Versailles
les Tongiens à Croissy-sur-Seine on sait
que vous êtes originaire des Yvelines ça
a une importance aussi pour vous d'avoir
ce lien de partager aussi la compétition
avec les territoires franciliens à
préciser que le choix des gants de base
est vraiment de la responsabilité des
équipes en aucun cas je n'ai été parti
prenante dans la décision c'est vraiment
les équipes qui ont décidé qui ont été
séduits par Versailles pour les Gallois
qui ont été ciblés séduits par
Croissy-sur-Seine pour les Tongiens mais
effectivement c'est une belle
reconnaissance pour le département les
campbas c'est important parce que c'est
là que vont loger les équipes pendant 4
5 semaines selon leur parcours pendant
la compétition et donc ils se sont
engagés auprès de nous avoir au moins un
événement voire plus ouvert au public
donc voilà la population locale pourra
voir peut-être un entraînement peut-être
autre chose il y aura une cérémonie
d'accueil qui sera également organisée
pour pour chacune de ces équipes et
chacune des villes donc effectivement
cette fête elle va être pas uniquement
dans les stades elle va être là aussi
dans les camps de base la France
c'est la déjà accueilli 2007 et on se
rappelle dans les Yvelines il y avait
déjà eu les Anglais qui étaient allés
dans les écoles qui avaient partagé la
culture on peut imaginer cela peut-être
avec les tonsiens une culture du
Pacifique qui peut être assez
impressionnante pour faire découvrir aux
élèves de Croissy-sur-Seine voilà ça
c'est vraiment à chaque ville avec
l'équipe de définir un peu froid moi
encore une fois nous le l'engagement des
équipes c'est au moins un événement
après bah c'est à l'équipe de séduire à
la ville pardon de ou au club hébergeant
à séduire l'équipe pour qu'ils aillent
un peu plus loin et effectivement qui
qui met en avant les valeurs du rugby au
travers de leur présence un dernier mot
en un mot votre état d'esprit là à 100
jours du 8 septembre France
Nouvelle-Zélande match d'ouverture au
Stade de France il est complexe c'est à
la fois une grande émotion parce que
aujourd'hui le trophée webbellis a été
vraiment amené d'Afrique du Sud par un
international sud-africain les derniers
champions du monde il y a 4 ans au Japon
et donc il nous transmettent le le
flambeau en quelque sorte il nous
transmettent le témoin nous disant voilà
maintenant c'est à vous à vous
d'organiser cette coupe du monde donc la
France va accueillir le monde donc c'est
vraiment beaucoup d'émotions et en même
temps beaucoup de sérénité parce qu'on
est très très bien préparé on a on a mis
un on a fait un travail exceptionnel
avec toutes les parties prenantes les
collectivités territoriales on est ici à
la région Île-de-France on est accueilli
par Valérie Pécresse et vraiment les les
collectivités sont vraiment derrière
l'événement World rugby la Fédération
française de rugby les sponsors et
vraiment on va faire une très très belle
coupe du monde on a hâte Jacques prévoit
merci beaucoup pour votre interview pour
votre disponibilité
[Musique]
avec moi Valérie Pécresse apprécié le
nom de la région Île-de-France vous avez
accueilli le dévoilement des médailles
de la Coupe du Monde qu'est-ce que ça
représente pour vous le rugby ben
d'abord c'est c'est une passion
d'enfance
moi j'ai toujours adoré le rugby et à
mon époque les filles ne jouaient pas au
rugby alors du coup j'ai jamais pu jouer
mais j'ai regardé et j'ai épousé un
corpsien donc un brieviste acharné donc
c'est une passion qu'on s'est transmise
de génération en génération j'ai un fils
qui a fait beaucoup beaucoup de rugby
dans sa jeunesse et du coup comment
avez-vous contribué à l'organisation de
la Coupe du monde alors pour moi le
sport d'une manière générale et le rugby
en particulier
ça unit les franciliens et cette coupe
du monde elle va être un grand moment de
cohésion l'Île-de-France va accueillir
une dizaine de matchs donc on va être
vraiment le centre de cette coupe du
monde et on veut en profiter évidemment
pour accueillir le monde l'accueillir
dignement montrait le sens de
l'hospitalité des franciliens et puis on
espère aussi qu'on va la gagner donc du
coup on est très fier on accueillera
trois équipes vous le savez l'équipe de
France à Rueil-Malmaison le Pays de
Galles l'équipe Tonga donc ça va être ça
va être un moment où toute l'Île de
France va se mettre à l'heure du rugby
c'est pour ça que nous avons acheté 5000
places 5000 places pour les jeunes
franciliens premier inscrit premier
service ce sera sur la base c'est la
plateforme la nouvelle plateforme où il
y aura tous les bons plans pour les
jeunes franciliens et elle ouvrira le 23
juin prochain merci Valérie Pécresse à
bientôt
[Musique]
et c'est l'heure maintenant d'ouvrir une
page loisir dans votre 7 8
[Musique]
et on ouvre cette page loisirs en
remontant le temps l'association hélium
qui met en valeur le patrimoine de la
Vallée de Chevreuse propose plusieurs
circuits pour découvrir ou redécouvrir
les lavoirs de nos petits villages le
reportage de Mélanie poquet et Régine
Radès
madame Olga
j'ai tombé mon savon dans le fond encore
ma petite Gervaise vous entendez
mesdemoiselles laver ses linge au 19e
siècle c'est ce que nous propose
d'imaginer l'association hélium jusqu'au
17 septembre un voyage à travers le
temps est proposé au public pour
découvrir les lavoirs cet équipement
d'hygiène essentielle à l'époque la
fonction de ce travail là c'est
interpellé se souvenir que des
lavandières ont travaillé ici ça a été
vivant il y a trois jours il y a une
dame de 87 ans qui est passé et qui a
été laveuse dans une dans un séchoir
dans un lavoir de tanneur juste à côté
c'est à la suite des grandes épidémies
et sous l'influence du mouvement
hygiéniste qu'une loi est promulguée en
1851 imposant à chaque commune
l'aménagement de bâtiments spécialement
dédié au lavage une histoire encore
inconnue pour de nombreux visiteurs
de la voir je sais pas d'où vient la
cette histoire mais c'était au cours et
percutant et intéressant j'ai trouvé que
c'était très original très touchant et
l'impression de revivre
le monde des lavandières avec la
participation du réseau patrimoine plus
de 70 la voie de la Vallée de Chevreuse
ont été recensés dont 32 retenus pour
aborder le thème de l'hygiène au 19e
siècle mis en valeur à l'aide de
performance photographie ou encore par
des sculptures il s'agit de rendre un
texte de leur rendre vivant autant que
possible et de restituer ce qui a été ce
que l'auteur ou l'autrice en
l'occurrence il y a beaucoup d'autrices
il y a un auteur quand même à écrit et
bien pouvoir transmettre cette histoire
là est réveillée c'est lavandière comme
ça qu'ils sont au bord de l'eau un
sommeil la balade propose quatre
circuits dont 3 dans le département des
Yvelines des balades plus ou moins
courtes et accessibles pour les grands
et les petits jusqu'au 17 septembre
toutes de temps circuler dans les conv
ersations oriait beaucoup
printemps avec les beaux jours en
perspective
et on poursuit cette page loisirs avec
vos idées de sortie Gabriel comme chaque
jeudi à l'approche du week-end vous nous
proposez vos meilleurs plans par quoi en
commun ce soir et bien vous allez
pouvoir profiter du soleil Mathilde avec
le retour des rendez-vous au jardin de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines les
rendez-vous au jardin c'est un événement
national l'objectif mettre à l'honneur
la richesse et la diversité des jardins
et des espaces verts mais aussi montrer
l'action des collectivités et des
propriétaires privés pour préserver ses
jardins près d'une dizaine de lieux sont
à découvrir sur le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines parmi eux la
ferme du bouloyer à Magny-les-Hameaux ou
le parc de la maison de l'Ermitage à
Bouvier qui se situe à Guyancourt pour
cette vingtième édition l'événement sera
placé sous le signe des musiques de
jardin et toujours dans cette thématique
de l'environnement trap organise sa
première fête de l'écologie oui tout à
fait Mathilde l'écologie est aujourd'hui
vous le savez un sujet à part entière et
les villes s'en emparent samedi 30
organisent une grande journée de
sensibilisation et d'éducation tout ça
dans un esprit de fête le but sus
trouver des engagements en faveur de la
transition écologique c'est aussi
l'occasion de mettre en lumière les
initiatives des trappistes dans leur
commune une vingtaine d'ateliers seront
proposés alors il y aura des ateliers de
fleurissement de l’échochauffage par
traction animale avec des chevaux ou
encore du vélo smoothie le principe un
vélo un blender et vous réalisez vos jus
à la force des jambes ces activités
elles sont proposées de 11 heures à 17h
devant le gymnase maillet à Trappes un
espace sera également aménagé pour
pique-niquer en famille et alors vous
nous avez parlé de vélo smoothie les
Illinois vont ainsi pouvoir courir ce
week-end Gabriel cette fois ça se passe
à Guyancourt la ville organise samedi
une urban color run pour les curieux qui
ne sont pas inscrits à la course vous
pouvez quand même venir profiter du
spectacle et des nombreuses activités
qui sont proposées alors au programme
roller skate trottinette atelier de
graphe ou encore Street basket toutes
les informations elles sont sur les
lieux pardon et les heures des
différentes activités sont à découvrir
sur le site de la ville de Guyancourt et
gagne une compagnie de théâtre
yvelinoise faite ses 40 ans pour
l'occasion un week-end de spectacle et
proposé oui pour ces 40 bougies la
troupe du crâne s'entourent de son
public alors la troupe elle a été fondée
en 1982 par la metteur en scène Monique
fondi Dion elle est basée historiquement
à Coignières et à Maurepas pour
l'événement de vendredi à dimanche à
Coignières plusieurs pièces seront
proposées parmi les pièces un fil à la
pâte ou encore des classiques comme le
Chat Potté beauté pardon Hansel et
Gretel ou le chaperon rouge des ateliers
Theatro seront proposés par les
collégiens et les lycéens une exposition
de photos et de souvenirs sur cette
troupe sera également proposé dans le
hall de l'espace à fond Alphonse Daudet
pendant plusieurs jours et on poursuit
avec le Salon des métiers d'art et de la
création ça sera à Rambouillet oui à
Rambouillet un salon qui revient pour la
cinquième édition toujours à la Bergerie
Nationale alors 56 artisans d'art et
créateurs d'exception de la Vallée de
Chevreuse mais aussi d'autres régions en
France viendront présenter leur création
et leur savoir-faire seront à découvrir
bijoux contemporains céramique
maroquinerie ou encore mosaïque de quoi
trouver des pièces uniques peut-être des
idées de cadeaux pour la fête des mères
le salon Mathilde se déroule du 3 au 4
juin c'est de 10h à 19h et justement
pour la fête des mères Gabriel vous avez
plusieurs autres idées de sortie oui
direction Maurepas notamment où les
bénévoles de fleurs et bouquet
s'affairent pour préparer leur
exposition d'art floral elle se déroule
au café de la plage de vendredi jusqu'à
dimanche l'occasion pour l'association
fondée en 1998 de fêter ses 25 ans au
programme création florale autour des
thématiques du recyclage des matériaux
ou encore du goût il y aura également
des démonstrations le samedi ça se passe
à 15h et il sera possible d'acheter un
beau bouquet pour votre maman on écoute
les propos recueillis par Grégory
canalet les personnes pourront regarder
un bouquet de fleurs fraîches et on
donnera les noms des végétaux des fleurs
et
va faire une démonstration
d'art moderne et peut-être un peu plus
classique
l'exposition elle ouvre demain à 14h et
se refermera dimanche à 17h30 l'entrée
est libre et dimanche France Miniature
faite aussi les mamans oui pour la fête
des mères le parc au 117 monument
miniature offre une entrée aux mamans
pour une entrée enfant ou adulte achetée
alors attention vous pouvez bénéficier
uniquement de cette offre aux caisses du
parc ce dimanche pour ça vous devez être
muni d'un livret de famille et d'une
pièce d'identité et ainsi que de la
photo que vous voyez s'afficher à
l'écran photo que vous pouvez retrouver
sur le compte Facebook de France
Miniature et bien merci beaucoup Gabriel
ça m'a donné des idées moi je trouve que
c'est dommage parce que si la maman de
Mathilde nous regarde c'est dommage
parce que Gabriel a spoilé le cadeau je
suis désolé pour vous la maman de Mathis
je suis désolé pour vous mais c'est
voilà
j'ai quand même d'autres petites idées
pour ce dimanche Nicolas mais bon est-ce
que vous vous avez déjà votre cadeau et
votre idée non mais je fais bien
mais je suis pas trop non j'ai pas envie
d'être spoilé par Gabriel et vous
Gabriel est-ce que vous avez déjà vous
avez déjà votre cadeau de sortie très
bien
bravo c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'oeil à la
météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera toujours aussi
bleu et ensoleillé dans les Yvelines au
niveau des températures il fera 13
degrés à Houdan Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles et 12 degrés à Rambouillet
dans l'après-midi le soleil sera
toujours au beau fixe côté température
compter 20 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie et
Versailles 21 à Houdeng et 22 à
Rambouillet et pour les prévisions météo
de ce week-end c'est le retour de notre
Mister météo Thomas Fletcher lui aussi
il s'est intéressé à la fête des mères
mais de sa manière particulière regardez
bonjour à toutes et à tous alors quoi de
beau ce week-end dans les Yvelines
j'espère que je vous ai pas trop manqué
depuis ces deux dernières semaines
sachez que pour me rattraper ce week-end
il va être bien chargé tout d'abord on
va au festival la tour mais les watts je
sais pas si vous connaissez moi je
connais c'est super on va aller à la
rencontre des techniciens qui sont
là-bas sur place en train d'installer le
festival on va voir si les enceintes
marchent en tout cas niveau Journée
Internationale on est gâté samedi c'est
la fête du vélo donc faites du vélo et
dimanche c'est la fête des mères mais
c'est aussi c'est la fête du nudisme
donc voilà la blague est faite Bonne
fête maman et bonne fête à toutes vos
mères et maintenant allons voir si les
enceintes elles marchent
en fait je pose des questions vraiment
essentielles la dimanche c'est la
journée internationale du nudisme moi
c'est un 7 journée en même temps il faut
des journées pour tout c'est la fête des
mères aussi dimanche ah ça je ne savais
pas non plus j'aime ma mère mais je suis
anti fête commerciale donc je la choille
tous les jours de l'année donc le
nudisme c'est une fête commerciale je ne
sais pas si c'est une fête commerciale
mais peut-être je ne sais pas s'il y a
des profits à faire pas dans le vêtement
je pense pas vous faites quoi vous là
sur l'événement nous sommes en
logistique donc c'est à dire que tout ce
que vous voyez qui est monté à droite à
gauche c'est nous qui l'avons monté donc
là les tentes là exactement
je m'occupe après à partir de demain
avec le monsieur là-bas en bermuda on
s'occupe de toute la partie VIP ici qui
va recueillir bénévole artiste élu
invité donc voilà donc là là on a reçu
tous les fûts toutes les tireuse waouh
il y a encore un camion qui arrive avec
des fûts chaque fût fait 30 litres
responsable bar public
un vrai contact faut le garder là vous
êtes tous bénévoles
OK
salut chef j'ai une question à te poser
en tant que régisseur général est-ce que
tu étais au courant que le naturisme ça
se fait tait ce dimanche là non j'étais
pas au courant mais après si les gens se
foutent à poils vont être obligés de les
sortir quoi ok donc là si il y a des
gens qui viennent à poil c'est pas c'est
un peu chaud je crois dommage
je vais garder les chemises tu peux
peut-être me filer une mission même si
tu veux je peux peut-être faire un truc
de débile tu peux faire un truc de
débile je suis capable de faire ça
Baptiste tu as pas un truc débile à
faire la canisse bah parfait tu vas
faire de la canisse allez faisons de la
canisse
est-ce que c'est un chien
est-ce que c'est un chien la canisse
pour l'enfer
en fait il va falloir en mettre déjà ici
pour que la
o à cette époque
le soir du festival je me déguiser en
dinosaure on peut voir ton costume ou
c'est
moi-même
on va essayer de trouver quelqu'un pour
un test bonne nuit tu as envie de faire
cobaye
maintenant qui lui cru les dinosaures
sont revenus
c'est un vrai fais un bruit c'est un
bruit
[Musique]
alors quoi de beau
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 et un excellent
weekend prenez soin de vous
[Musique]